now is the time when things are shifting
we're gonna they're gonna be a new world
order out there
and i for one welcome our new insect
overlords
all right people i'm dave rubin and
we've got another friday panel
extravaganza joining me today our host
of the liz wheeler show liz wheeler and
fox news columnist and new york post
columnist
two columnists that's a lot of calm this
thing uh carol markowitz we had robert
barnes but the internet gremlins did
something to him a few minutes ago and
he can't join us so it's an all lady
panel how are you ladies
how's it going hi dave hi carol
i am glad to have the two of you because
uh this was another crazy week it's
always a crazy week but i feel like
something happened this week that
leveled up the the craziness and i know
that you guys will give me
some good insight on to this this new
world order thing that biden just sort
of slipped out oh there's a new world
order coming somehow i don't remember
that do you guys remember that during
the campaign was there anything about
new world order coming you guys remember
that was there anything i don't think so
uh but that just slipped out so
that's what he's throwing at us let's
show you the full
clip on that and then we'll jump in
you know we are at an inflection point i
believe in the world economy not just
the world economy in the world it occurs
every three or four generations
as one of them as the one of the top
military people said to me in a secure
meeting the other day
60 60 million people died between 1900
and 1946
and uh since then we established a
liberal world order and that hadn't
happened in a long while a lot of people
dying but nowhere near the chaos
and now is the time when things are
shifting we're gonna they're gonna be a
new world order out there and we've
gotta lead it we've gotta unite the rest
of the free world in doing it
okay so putting aside the lack of energy
the odd telling us that the new world
order is coming and sort of threatening
us that an awful lot of people are going
to die he puts that out there and it
doesn't get a lot of traction on
mainstream media and before i throw you
guys i want to show one other thing
twitter trending immediately told us
that it wasn't even true what he said
right there it was trending in politics
unfounded claims about the new world
order conspiracy theory are discussed
after president joe biden used the
phrase as he spoke about the united
states response to russia's invasion of
ukraine during an address at business
roundtables ceo
quarterly
meeting so don't worry guys even though
joe biden said that there's a new world
order twitter cleaned it up for him real
quick uh carol i'll jump to you first on
this because uh you
work at the new york post and the other
thing that we were covering pretty
heavily this week was the whole hunter
biden thing
um yeah who do you believe here do you
believe twitter or do you believe joe
biden
well i think neither really i i think oh
i don't know where joe biden got this
new world order from or where he
imagined he would be the one leading it
uh i i think we're in a really crazy
place with joe biden as our president
where
nobody really believes that he's the guy
in charge which is difficult for a new
world order uh when the guy is declaring
that he's going to be the man running it
um and nobody thinks he's the man
running anything
so it's it's a really wild situation to
watch him on the world stage and be kind
of nervous that
other countries are seeing this they're
seeing our president sort of stumbling
um and talking about kind of crazy
things
liz what do you think about biden saying
it i mean did he just kind of slip or
did i mean you know they give him the
script he reads usually quite poorly off
the paper or the prompter i mean it
doesn't seem like it was something he
was supposed to say
well i this was so hilarious to me when
i first saw this headline and then i
watched the clip for myself to make sure
that the headline wasn't out of context
this was hilarious to me because like
two or three years ago if anyone said
the phrase new world order they were
castigated by the left for being
conspiracy theorists this this doesn't
exist this isn't a real thing you tin
foil hat crazies we were told and then
obviously you know two three years later
joe biden says it himself and now i'd
love to hear from those same those same
liberals those same mainstream media
outlets that said that there was no such
thing as a new world order but twitter
actually this is a very interesting and
telling warning or i guess it was more
of a summary that twitter put out
because if we lived in a society where
journalists were curious where they had
any kind of journalistic integrity they
would ask the question well what do you
mean you and i dave and carol wouldn't
have to sit here and speculate did joe
biden mean to say this did he not mean
to say this was this an accident who
wrote this for him because journalists
would be asking the question they say mr
president that phrase is attached to
accusations of globalism from some
people in accusations of conspiracy from
other people could you clarify what that
means what do you mean by a new world
order what do you mean by we might take
the lead because there is an effort by
people not just in our country but
around the world to have a globalist
world order to have these these bodies
above the sovereignty of nations ruling
us i mean this is what the world
economic forum wants to do this is what
the united nations wants to do and there
are politicians in our country who want
to give away our sovereignty to these
extra governmental bodies and so if we
had a journalistic class that had any
integrity at all they would say mr
president what do you mean when you say
new world order yeah and it's not just
that it's not just that we don't have a
journalistic class but connor real quick
could you throw the tweet up again the
the screenshot of what twitter put there
unfounded claims so first off he's the
one that said new world order they start
the sentence with unfounded claims and
then the implication is that if you talk
about it you're a conspiracy theorist uh
carol go ahead yeah no i was just gonna
say exactly to that point that somebody
at twitter understood the reference
whereas joe biden did not somebody at
twitter was like wait we can't have the
president saying this this is a term
used by people to mean something very
specific and the president maybe didn't
mean it or you know they cover up for
him but somebody at twitter literally
understood
what the implications of that was in a
way that joe biden did not carol i want
to go a little further on the on the
twitter part of this because the other
big thing of course the last week was
the the hunter biden story which the new
york times confirmed and now basically
we're done it's over again you know it's
like we had two years of we couldn't
talk about it new york times finally
admits it's real and then sort of maybe
us and some of the online people talk
about it for a day or two and now it's
gone again but as someone that works at
the new york post which was suspended
the links were unable to be posted by
other people and everything else
um it's sort of directly connected to
this story that that twitter is now more
important than the journalistic outlets
and as liz said we don't really have
that many journalists in the first place
right and you were unable to direct
message that link to somebody if i
wanted to send it to you in a private
message on twitter or facebook or
instagram i would have been unable to
and so i think again going back to i a
lot of things are really scary right now
so i'm going to keep using that word but
this is scary that that uh social media
platforms have this kind of control over
what people get to read and see and
learn about um and the joke of course is
that the new york times didn't produce
any new information to confirm that the
hunter by the story
they simply looked into it a little
deeper when it no longer mattered and
the thing is and obviously this is a
question that you know just kind of gets
asked because of the timing but why why
did the new york times do this now and
it you know it's not not a really
conspiracy theory to say that they
probably are looking to the future and
they are not sure that they want joel
biden to be the candidate in 2024 and i
can't blame them for that but this is a
really targeted specific way
to get at the biden family to look at an
old story and say oh we've discovered
something new there is nothing new here
liz i suspect you're not surprised that
none of those 50 intelligence officers
who issued the statement saying you know
that it was complete misinformation two
years ago nobody's retracted anything
nobody's apologized we know nothing of
who decided to do this at twitter two
years ago nobody's asking the questions
as you said before we just don't have
journalists
carol you must know somebody could you
call somebody and ask somebody to
call somebody at twitter and say who is
in the meeting who you know right really
that's what people should be looking at
who is in the meeting at twitter
to say okay we're to ban this thing but
liz i'm surprised you're not surprised
by any of this obviously
no i'm not surprised because the 50
intelligence officers who said that this
was a conspiracy theory they've ruined
that term by the way because now no
one's ashamed to be associated with
so-called conspiracy theories because
they all come true um but these these
intelligence officers made a deliberate
choice at that time they did not believe
that it was untrue they just wanted you
and i to think that it was untrue they
wanted the american people to think it
was untrue so of course they're not
going to retract they lied once they're
fine lying again here yeah the actual
problem here though isn't the mainstream
media the mainstream media is part of
the problem but the bigger problem that
we shouldn't forget that we shouldn't
overlook is what hunter biden did the
fact that his emails showed that he was
selling access to his father when his
father was vice president of the united
states under the obama administration
that he was taking money from foreign
entities tied to hostile governments and
that he was saving part of that money
for the big guy for his father this is
the reason it's a bombshell story it's
not really a bombshell story that he's a
crack addict that's a sad part of it
that explains some of his behavior but
that's actually it's not just for family
shame that we talk about hunter biden
it's not just to embarrass biden it's
because his behavior put the national
security of our country at risk and so i
think conservatives do need to be really
careful when they're talking about this
story not just to focus on how awful the
new york times is or how awful twitter
are which they are of course but focus
on the actual crime that was committed
because there was a poll that showed
that democrats who voted for joe biden
in 2020 um that they there's a good
percentage of them who wouldn't have
voted for joe biden if they had believed
the hunter biden story to be true and so
um we need to focus on that i think more
than the media aspect
carol at some level again because you're
at the post and you probably know
personally some of the people involved
in this i mean at some level this really
was election interference the fact that
they would not let us get this
information
right i think what liz is saying is
exactly right this wasn't a story about
look at the president's crackhead son it
absolutely is not about hunter biden's
problems it is about what hunter biden
did while joe biden was vice president i
and i i think that had americans heard
that
his son is so compromised and had uh
accepted payment to connect to his dad i
think it would have been a really
different story
that's the thing i think you know liz
mentioned that conspiracy theorists are
no longer like a bad term that's where
we are now and it's a bad place to be i
don't like that americans don't trust
anything i don't think it's a good thing
that we can't trust the media at all
that we don't trust most of our
institutions at all that we know that
we're being lied to and that nobody will
do anything about it
all of that is bad in my opinion i think
as a cohesive country uh we can't be we
can't be in that place and be a cohesive
country at the same time and i think we
all know that
all right well putting aside our crazy
conspiracy theories and the wacky ideas
that you guys are talking about biden
continued in that speech yesterday and
he's warning us you remember about two
months ago and for a month he warned us
that uh there was going to be a war
coming with russia and ukraine now he's
warning us about food shortages here we
go
nothing more to report with regard to
food shortage yes we did we
still talk about food shortages
and uh and it's going to be real
the price of these sanctions is not just
imposed upon russia it's imposed upon an
awful lot of countries as well including
european countries and our country as
well
ah so the sanctions are going to cause
us and the europeans to have food
shortages um liz where we promised that
a couple weeks ago when this thing
started i don't remember anything about
food shortages right here at home i mean
we're shortage of we're having shortages
of everything else so i guess we should
have expected it but i don't remember
that
well i think there's a couple things i
mean i myself was waiting during this
speech for biden to mention whether um
his transportation secretary buda judge
was actually back to his job whether he
was going to address the supply chain
crisis that we've been experiencing that
does lead to food shortages the the
other reason this is true right everyone
who goes to a grocery store which means
not joe biden understands that prices
have been hiked really high i mean a
gallon of milk is a lot more expensive
um diapers i buy diapers for my daughter
they're a lot more expensive this is a
this is a real thing that we're dealing
with and the reason is it's not just
arbitrary it's not just happening it's
happening because of deliberate
political decisions that joe biden has
made whether it's spending which leads
to um inflation whether it's not
addressing the supply chain crisis
whether it's environmental policies that
have that have hurt our farmers across
the country that have either driven
prices up or driven the supply down this
is this is joe biden being out of touch
once again and i i'm excited in a sense
to see how this plays out in the
midterms because people are hurting and
he's just being flippant about it carol
i want to focus on one word that liz
said right there deliberate because all
week i did shows this whole week
basically my argument at this point is
that this is deliberate i think that
they actually do want these supply chain
issues i think they want food shortages
i think they want high gas prices they
are trying to usher in his words a new
world order and you'd have to collapse
the system and make everyone think this
thing doesn't work so so when people say
that oh no they're just bad at what they
do it's like no they're actually quite
good at it what do you think about that
i don't know i you know the problem with
that and i i get why that could be a
theory of what's happening because
everything makes no sense um but the
problem with that is at the end of that
who chooses like the biden
administration or democrats in general
to lead the way on this new world order
um
when this everything has collapsed
around them i think one of the things is
that we don't hear from joe biden that
often and when we do hear from them it's
always like winter of despair is coming
it's like
it's never like don't worry i'm gonna
make things better for everybody it's
always like prepare for the worst we're
all gonna die
so i don't really know why that's the
strategy that his cam you know his
administration has come up with for when
we do see the president he's always
there to deliver the worst possible news
to us um i think food shortages are
coming i don't think they have anything
to do with the with the war on russia i
think people have been predicting these
food shortages for a while i think we're
seeing in stores a lack of supply it it
completely comes back to this
administration being inept and not
caring that this is affecting people on
a very day-to-day basis and it just
they're the world of you know the
delayed treadmill etc they have no idea
what's really happening out there in
america yeah by the way congratulations
on to you guys for surviving the winter
of death and uh michael lowe's had a
great point we went from like the winter
of death to now the spring of food
shortages it's just incredible the way
they use fear but but that's pretty much
all they got at this point right liz
yeah certainly i mean it's emotional
manipulation it's emotional blackmail i
think that the the threats for the
spring aren't going to be quite as
frightening to people as the threats of
kovid but this is what they do i mean
think about how they act on climate
change they tell us in 11 years or i
guess it's ten years but now you haven't
noticed that they changed their talking
points which is interesting they're
still saying 11 years three years in a
row in 11 years the world is going to
end if we don't if we don't stop eating
red meat and stop using airplanes and if
we don't sacrifice our souls on the
altar of socialism here they do the same
thing with covet if we don't give away
our freedoms then you will die and you
will be killing grandma now you know
you're not gonna have food for your
family if you don't if you don't let let
the democrats turn our country into a
marxist state i mean at some at some
point they're gonna have adrenal burnout
syndrome i would think just from this
constant hyping um but i i don't know i
i would hope that the american people at
some point would realize listen these
predictions are not coming true these
predictions are inaccurate it is
fear-mongering and i i i do think it's a
deliberate strategy i do think that you
are correct when you say that it's a
deliberate strategy because in order to
usher in the america that they want or
the governing system of our country that
they want a socialist communist marxist
system they have to destroy our
institutions first this is classic
critical theory this is marxism um and
so they know that this is a part of
conditioning the public to do that carol
which would you say is worse if it's
deliberate or not deliberate which is
actually worse i mean if it's deliberate
then it feels like oh we can fight it
because we know there's something direct
to point at i mean if it's complete
ineptitude i'll play i'll pretend that
that sounds right like that's much
scarier in a way right
right well that's that's exactly it i
i'm not sure which the conspiracy theory
is at this point but no i think it is an
ineptitude i think this administration
has no idea what's going on and and
they're just completely out of touch i
just i remember you know joe biden going
on vacation as the afghanistan thing
fell apart and it's just like how do you
do that how do you go home to delaware
when americans are dying in a country
that you know we've been in for so long
and you you pulled out haphazardly and
really um didn't care about them and so
i you know
liz said that america she hopes
americans see through what's going on
and i i really do think americans have
gotten very savvy and that they
understand a lot more than they say used
to and they're able to see the angles in
a way that they hadn't maybe in the past
um i think they see this administration
for what it is i think they they know
that um things are going badly and it's
the direct result of this administration
and their policies whether or not that's
intentional is a separate issue but i
think americans really do know where
this begins and ends uh i hope you are
right well whether it's intentional or
not here is one of biden's top economic
advisors by the name of brian diese
telling us that we're probably going
into a recession or maybe not but it
sort of has something to do with them
and also nothing to do with them as it
begins to tighten policy are you
confident that the fed won't tighten
into a recession
look i don't think anybody can be 100
confident of anything at this point
we're uh in uncertain territory i think
that that's the
task that they have in front of them and
they are what i'm confident of is that
they will do that with care and with
precision and with independent judgment
and that that is the best that we
can expect
pretty inspirational huh i don't think
anyone could be confident of anything
this is a white house spokesman
i said she said i don't have a question
for you just say something
well listen the road tell is paved with
good intentions so even if you think
that this dude from the white house and
i call him that deliberately because he
is in no position uh to be admired here
even if he even if he just doesn't know
what he's doing um he the rotel's paid
with good intentions i mean he's gonna
he's they're leading the country into a
financial crisis that's obvious you can
see what's happening here i personally
like i said i think it's deliberate
because i think that they're surrounding
themselves whether or not biden himself
is aware of this stuff that i don't know
i mean the guy is senile he belongs in a
nursing home you hear him i mean he's
practically shuffling i expect him to
show up with velcro shoes any day but
the fact of the matter is he surrounds
himself with people who do know what
they're doing he surrounds himself with
financial advisors who espouse modern
monetary theory this bananas idea that
the government can just or should as the
issuer of currency just continue to
spend that they shouldn't worry about
debt they shouldn't worry about deficit
they should only worry about the amount
that they spend as it relates to
inflation and when inflation becomes too
high then they just raise taxes so that
it decreases demand on the supply i mean
these are the people that biden
surrounds himself with and we know that
the ultimate result of that kind of
crazy monetary theory is going to be
economic ruin again i think they're
leading us to economic ruin because they
want economic ruin to take down the
institutions so that they can uh so that
they can impose instead socialism but
the fact of the matter is these people
surrounding biden are
are crazy they're very radical and
deliberately so carol you're you're a
mother if your kids came to you and they
had a problem
and your response was well i don't think
anyone could be confident of anything
and i can't really trust anybody et
cetera et cetera would this be a good
way of parenting
you know it's funny because that clip
really did remind me of my children that
little shrug in the beginning like who
color who colored on the walls
i don't know could be anyone really
anything is possible
um i really think that shrug has to be
memed because that's really a perfect
encapsulation of what's going on at the
biden administration just that little
like i don't know it could be anything
really um yeah i think that it's an
irresponsible way to talk to the
american people and say that you know
anything is possible prepare for the
worst
start hoarding food etc
this administration really doesn't
understand that they their policies are
leading to a lot of problems but their
communication is just really abysmal
what about the way that they sort of
also it's not just the strange wording
and the double speak and all that stuff
but the blatant lies i mean things that
we that we all know are true that if you
just print money endlessly you will
deflate the value of money it's basic
economics 101 everyone understands it
you can learn it from monopoly if you
didn't learn it in school is this also
just the problem of education at this
point that we have so many people who
have been poorly educated that you can't
blame these people for trying to take
advantage of the situation liz
yeah definitely i mean it's it's twofold
in education they're not only children
or not only and not not just children
young adults in college are not only not
taught good sound economics they are
actively taught not to think critically
and they're actively taught that it's
not their place to
question the experts you know we're
basically raising children in this
brainless technocracy where only certain
people with certain degrees as bestowed
by radical leftist institutions are
allowed to speak on certain issues it's
like the katanji brown jackson well i
can't tell you what a woman is i'm not a
biologist like are you joking lady you
are a woman define a woman this is this
is this is well not to make a bad pun
here this is not rocket science you can
take part in this um so yeah so it's the
fault of bad education but you can tell
what people are believing just i'm gonna
go off of something carol said she said
we talked about food hoarders i mean are
you guys are you guys stockpiling food
like do you guys have emergency food i
do my husband's a somewhat of a prepper
we have emergency food because we know
what's coming even if you can't write
down that economics algorithm in your
notebook like people know what the
result of these behaviors from the biden
administration are going to be i've got
a freezer in my garage stocked with all
kinds of good stuff that you guys are
both welcome to during the apocalypse
i'm coming
so we basically should have known this
was all coming right if they told us two
plus two was five they told us that boys
are girls of course the next thing would
be that that nothing you know related to
math and economics actually has any
meaning
right or the covered years right two
years of nothing making sense like these
people don't have to be vaccinated but
these people do have to be vaccinated
these people don't have to mask but
these people do have to mess and none of
it it made any sense and we were
screaming you know into the void about
it for two years and the left still
doesn't want to face up to any of that
but you know the thing about
inflation is that it really can be
explained in a really simple way i'm
telling you you can talk to my
nine-year-old and he'll explain why
printing too much money will lead to
prices becoming higher um and i i don't
think this is a complicated concept i
think it just needs to be put out there
but instead we have you know the biden
administration saying that this money
printing thing that they're doing has
nothing to do with inflation that it has
to you know putin did it it's always
putin at this point um and
i don't know i don't know that americans
understand that they should be kind of
not affording okay like
you know not everybody can have a
freezer in their garage but they
absolutely should be stacking up with an
eye on the future for sure carol is your
son looking for a job because i'm pretty
sure would you like to interview him he
could be head of the fed i mean i'll
hire him for something but he could be
head of the fed all right let's keep
looking let's do one more thing here
that sort of i guess captures this whole
thing i mean biden is just losing it he
just is it's a sad depressing reality we
can all joke about it all the time and i
do and then my mom always says stop
joking about it so much because it's
actually quite sad he's the pilot of the
plane and the pilot is clearly incapable
uh here he is yesterday when he uh
thought he was just going to freely take
some questions
and i'll be now happy to take your
questions since there's so many people
out there i'm gonna been given a list
now how about chris or the associated
press first question
so they hand him a list we don't know
who they is and then when other people
try to ask him questions they get pushed
away and rushed away i'm fairly certain
if this was the orange guy the media
would be screaming about it
carol it's it's depressing right like we
don't whether you like the guy or not
whether you think that they're trying to
usher in the new world order or not this
isn't the way it's supposed to be
right whether you like him or not is
irrelevant here because i i think we
need to hear from our president you
don't have to agree with him you don't
have to disagree with him we need to
hear him speak we need to hear him talk
to the american people and again every
time he talks to us he says something
crazy and we're all like wait what um
but in general we don't hear from him
that often and the fact that he only
goes to media that is his preferred
media people you know i don't know i
don't know who chris at associated press
is but but that chris said associated
press should know that he's being chosen
because they think that he's going to be
um you know kinder to biden or or just
softer
if i'm chris i i i don't think that
looks particularly great for me that
they're confident i'm not going to ask a
difficult question and throw the
president off his game
liz did you happen to see the other part
in this speech we should have grabbed
the clip where he goes in again in on
the very fine people hoax and he says
that you know this is why he decided to
run for president because trump said
there were very fine people in
charlottesville and we know and i've
debunked it a million times and all the
internet conspiracy theorists have done
the same thing where trump immediately
did condemn the white supremacists and
the neo-nazis but that biden is just
repeating lies that are put in front of
him he doesn't know what he's saying and
i just don't know what to do at this
point
well it's interesting i i did a whole
episode on my show last week about this
trifecta of i called it this trifecta of
evil that's happening in our country
where we have corrupt politicians who
don't want to be held accountable to
their voters they're doing things like
what hunter biden did they're doing
things like uh trying to spend our money
like with the modern monetary theory i
don't need to give you an example of all
the corrupt things they're doing we have
corrupt politicians we all understand
that but the reason they're able to get
away with their corruption is twofold
it's because we have big tech that's
censoring reality they're censoring any
information that would expose the
corruption right they're creating this
information vacuum by saying nope if you
if you if you send a link about hunter
biden we are going to actively stop you
from doing that because we don't want
you to hear about this story and then in
this vacuum of information that they've
created then the mainstream media comes
in and they propagate lies they're not
the censors they're the ones who are
telling you actually now that we have
the truth out of the way here's what we
want you to believe and it's only
because of this trifecta these three
these three parts of this apparatus that
corrupt politicians are actually able to
get away with their corruption otherwise
we would find out and we would never
stand for it this would be a bipartisan
rejection of this kind of corruption
that that's what we see with the story
about charlottesville this this very
fine people narrative from the left we
we know empirically what the truth is
this is not a controversial thing to say
you can look up the video yourself
trump actually said except for white
supremacists and neo-nazis like he was
not talking about them i condemn totally
big tech censors conservative yeah he
condemned them totally he did and he did
it again and again and big text censors
conservatives who who try to tell the
truth and then the mainstream media
comes in with with their false narrative
and that's what people believe the only
reason biden is able to get away with
his corruption and lies is because of
big tech and the mainstream media that's
why he calls on these people because
they are a critical part of his
apparatus
carol as someone that works at the post
and and fox and columnist and
journalists i mean do you remember when
it really went so haywire with so many
of your colleagues or so many of the
people at these other organizations
you know i think it is
trump i think that was the moment where
they lost it where they no longer even
pretended to see themselves as some
arbiters of truth they became
you know anti-trump as as a position and
as a job i remember brian stelter
working this out kind of publicly and
saying like are we supposed to like
um you know fact check trump in real
time are we supposed to uh ask questions
that we know he's gonna you know not
tell the truth to but as if that's only
limited to trump right they're not
backing anybody else so it became like
our mission is no longer
to be journalists where i you know i i
liberal media has always been a thing
it's not like that's new it's not like
they've um
just began pushing their positions but i
think what changed is the openness with
which they do it and the way that they
have changed their
entire focus uh it's it's really no
longer about telling american people the
truth it's about telling american people
the story that they think that american
people need to hear right and by the way
it's like you gotta sort of admire the
machine to your point liz because they
can get away with the lies because then
there's big tech and the machinery that
we're always playing catch up and trying
to whack them all of the lies we're all
running behind that we do need a little
bit of a paradigm shift which is my
final question which is uh you guys know
how i try to do this show i try to give
people at the end especially on a friday
like the vision of the positive vision
of how we get through this thing and how
we make some sense of it and how as i
know you guys both as friends you can
live good happy lives in the in in the
midst of this lunacy liz how can we do
it
uh well i mean i i say this
tongue-in-cheek in a sense because i am
myself obsessed with politics of course
but make sure that you have your
perspectives in proper order i mean you
should be spending time with your family
you should be spending time with your
spouse you should be having children you
should be going to church you should be
having a community you should be
pursuing hobbies you should be doing
things for enjoyment you should be
partaking in charity i mean all of these
things i mean i know i sound like a
preacher at this point but all of these
things are the joy of life the reason
that that we're in politics the reason
that we're in political commentary the
reason that we're in media is to protect
those things now so often we have so
much passion for what we do that we get
i should speak for myself here i get
obsessed with it i i'm a workaholic by
nature because i love what i do but i i
have to make sure that i don't lose
sight of those things because um those
are the joys of life so what i do on the
weekend is i spend time with my husband
i spend time with my daughter i spend
time with my family and my friends and i
i do the things that we are fighting to
protect and so i like i said i know this
sounds cliche it sounds cheesy but this
is this is what we as conservatives have
to remember to do it also helps us order
what we need to protect politically
based on what we want to do with our
families
carol politics shouldn't be everything
well
it
answer is not not
opposed to that for sure i i focus on my
family above all and focus on my
friendships i i think that it's
very important to take a breaks you know
long breaks from twitter um i remember
the twitter's not real life but i will
say that i think i'm very hopeful right
now because i think so many eyes have
been opened over the last especially two
years where i don't think we're letting
our kids get indoctrinated in quite the
same way that we used to i think that we
are super involved now in what our kids
are learning not just in school but
what they're learning on tv shows what
they're learning through books
i think parents have been
you know finally awoken and they
understand that something is targeting
their children and they are fighting
back so my hopeful thing is that parents
have realized just how much politization
of their children is happening and
they're
ready to fight that and they are
fighting that and i think they're
winning i really do i think the last few
weeks have really been
encouraging to me that sanity will
prevail
that's a that's a solid note to end on
well i want to thank you two women
although we know this week that
technically we're not sure what a woman
is i'm not a biologist so i apologize if
i've offended either one of you i'm
gonna finish up for a couple minutes but
have a great weekend guys and carol i'm
gonna have that gelato that you sent me
tonight so thank you very much
uh all right guys so yeah i think that's
the right take i really think that's the
right take i think they both hit
good points there at the end liz's point
of you just got to go live your life and
be with people you love and do things
you love to do and do charity and be
part of your community like that's the
point uh and then carol's point that the
silver lining to all of this which is
much harder to see is that so many
people are waking up i mean the messages
that i get from you guys so much of my
audience is filled with people that are
waking up as i once woke up years ago so
that really is the message actually i
would say that mostly when people say hi
to me
on the street or at a store or something
else they'll be like oh you know i was a
lefty a year ago or i didn't get any of
this a year ago or i saw you and larry
elder and this and that the other thing
and it's like that means that tons and
tons of people are waking up and i think
kovid woke a lot of people up i think
some of this obvious nonsense that we
just went through uh on this show today
with biden it's like it's pretty damn
obvious and maybe that means that the
machine will just hit down harder maybe
that means that more censorship will be
ramped up maybe that means that they'll
just try to scare us more and more
covent ii is coming back food shortages
are coming back nuclear war
but i think we're going to be all right
but but it's on us and actually
i wrote a book about it
can you believe it it's right here and
it's coming out in a couple weeks april
12th is when the book comes out but the
book tour
comes
starting on april 19th i'll be in
orlando florida then i'll be in west
palm beach on the 19th i'll be in
clearwater on the 20th uh april 21st in
raleigh north carolina april 22nd in
atlanta georgia the 23rd in chicago 24th
in dallas washington d.c on the 25th
west nyack new york on the 26th then i
have a little bit of a break than brea
california in
brea california in brea california may
12th oxnard california may 15 san jose
california may 16 phoenix arizona may
18th denver colorado we'll add some
other dates you can go to daverubin.com
events and dennis prager's joining me
larry elder's joining me oh we just
announced uh don jr donald trump jr you
know this guy he's going to join me in
west palm beach
on april 19th uh we've got benny johnson
we've got janmi park in chicago it's
just it's just a great group of people
it's going to be fun i hope you guys
will will join us and have a fun night
out
that's all we've got for you today i
hope you enjoyed the shows this week i
did and i hope you have a great weekend
and uh you don't stare at your phone the
whole time and you get out there and get
some fresh air and enjoy your loved ones
that is all
see you on monday
you